[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants beaux soirs le petit
ami patron vous croyez que je dois
descendre chez pas pr neil unis colin ni
oui bon mais j'y vais pour vous faire
plaisir
j'y vais
damman ils sont six copains m'ont
l'échelle
[Musique]
des p o il viendra moi je donne et qui
viendra tu as raison la faille à
[Musique]
cherry bomb mois
oulala que va-t-il se passer
nous avons préparé une surprise alors je
mens 20 rue d'auch
c'est une joute idiot près nous avons
appris une belle chanson
[Musique]
bond aux
amants
chatou mac en tirelire à lire à mon beau
chaud tout matin tirelire l'on me
montrer plus pour ma part tirelire à
l'erreur le nôtre est
attendu à lui remis nous le détruire ou
ma tante et reliera les run ou le
détruire à quand y redire au long de
laquelle trône répond matin sur l'ironie
pour laquelle propre trou maintenant
durant les relous c'est le quai fois la
matière à dire guerre est celle que
femme a donc revu ma vie que lui tendre
époux patent turlure que lui tendre
maths en tirant les relous julie
échouera quincaillerie mounir toujours
liche matin qu'ils veulent nous ne
voulons pas ma tirelire le nouveau four
le
martyre wali
bisounours on chatouille il est plus
beau que celui de mycologues au nom les
miens clément ils sont tous les deux
aussi beau l'un que l'autre est votre
chanson est un ravissant top
c'était pas une blague ces oeuvres
allons les petits prix
quel enfant exemple heures
[Musique]
nenê vous êtes tellement gentil que
demain c'est moi qui vous ferait une
surprise
vous verrez vous verrez demain la jette
à la lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mon bon nounours patron ils ont
été adorables
demain je le referai une grande surprise
ce qu'ils vont être étonnés dany des
enfants à demain fait pour
[Musique]
oh
m
avant
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]